im niedersächsischen beverstedt war die
online versorgung jahrelang schlecht
doch jetzt kommt endlich schnelles
internet glasfaser wird direkt bis ins
haus verlegt hier reist gerade die firma
ewe den boten auf um ein kabel zu
verlegen bekloppt denn genau an der
gleichen stelle hat vor kurzem die firma
deutsche glasfaser ein identisches kabel
vergraben die weberstädter sind genervt
von dieser unnötigen doppelten buddelei
ich bin schockiert darüber ich finde es
total drollig dass man zweimal in
glasfasernetze in unserem kleinen
idyllischen dörfchen hier verlegt das
ist doch blödsinn was sie machen das ist
jetzt genau die gleichen straßen mit
genau der gleichen technik hier
ausgestattet wird das ist für viele
einfach unverständlich und bringt die
leute ein bisschen auf die barrikaden
jahrelang will niemand im ländlichen
bieber steht glasfaser verlegen aber
dann fängt im frühjahr die deutsche
glasfaser mit dem ausbau an kaum ist
deren bautrupp fertig kommt die nächste
baukolonne diesmal von der ewe ag
der konzern der die niedersächsischen
städten und landkreisen gehört will sich
das lukrative internet geschäft nicht
entgehen lassen absurd wo erst gar kein
kabel liegt werden jetzt unnötigerweise
zwei verbuddelt was aber noch verrückter
ist ortsteile die etwas außerhalb liegen
bekommen gar kein glasfaserkabel für die
reicht es nicht mehr obwohl hier
millionen verbuddelt werden
deshalb muss auch dieses busunternehmen
weiter in der internet steinzeit leben
natürlich funktion stars also wir sind
ja abgeschnitten hier
wir bekommen keine leitung aktuell die
deutsche glasfaser weist jede schuld von
sich schließlich sei man zuerst da
gewesen
also es ist jedem netzausbau selbst
überlassen ob er die entscheidung trifft
ein bestehendes glasfasernetz zu
überbauen wir von der deutschen
glasfaser vermeiden dass wir über bauen
generell nicht wie ewe hatte als zweiter
gebuddelt findet das aber trotzdem okay
ja es liegt zwei mal etwas dass es
wettbewerb wir haben dort ein netz das
wir ausbauen
in beverstedt aber halten die bürger die
entscheidungen der unternehmen für
ausgemachten blödsinn
es schadet
mit ressourcen die im moment ja knapp
sind in dem bereich arbeitszeit material
dass da so verschwenderisch mit
umgegangen wird sondern wie braucht kein
menschen doppelt internetanschluss und
so haben viele weberstädter in den
kommenden wochen ungewollt zum zweiten
mal eine baustelle vor der türe
dafür muss der rest des ortes noch jahre
darauf warten dass in sachen
digitalisierung überhaupt mal was
passiert